ich habe mir die Monopoly Reise Edition
gekauft um das Spiel in relax zu spielen
das heißt immer dorthin zu fliegen wo
ich im Spiel lande ich habe es mehrere
Tage durchgezogen weil es war echt hart
aber echt richtig krasse Sachen erleben
wir vielleicht schon wisst ist das erste
Ziel für mich die Küste von Lagos und
Portugal gewesen und von da aus muss ich
den ersten nachflug nehmen Valencia wow
18 €, also bin ich zum Flughafen gesetzt
habe den ersten Flug gebucht und dieser
hat mich nach Valencia gebracht die
Stadt habe ich dann ein bisschen
erkundet beim Cologne market hat was
leckeres gegessen da muss man an dieser
Stelle mal loswerden Valencia ist eine
verdammt geile Stadt übrigens befinde
ich mich gerade hier im Schottland also
ich bin halt immer noch unterwegs ist
zwar manchmal wirklich super anstrengend
diese ganze Reiserei aber wenn ihr nicht
mehr verpassen wollt muss noch weiter so
hingeht dann folgt mir auf jeden Fall